alors nous verrons si un certain nombre
d'états membres
certains souhaitent abonder au budget
delà de la pac nous nous avons à
travailler sur notre cadre financier
pluriannuel bien évidemment il faudra
tenir compte du départ du royaume-uni au
niveau de l'europe est de faire en sorte
que avec cette baisse de 5% du budget
c'est à peu près ce qui se passera sur
la pac
regardez comment nous pouvons être
malgré tout très offensif là dessus ce
qui compte c'est que les ambitions de la
pac ne bouge pas ce qui compte c'est que
nous puissions faire en sorte de créer
les conditions où la pac demain elle
sera en mesure de bien protéger nos
agriculteurs nous souhaitons maintenir
je dirais les paiements directs sur le
premier pilier
c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait pas de
cofinancement et quand j'entends la
petite musique qui voudrait dire que
nous souhaitons renationaliser la pac
je dis non nous ne souhaitons pas
renationaliser la pac nous souhaitons
faire en sorte que les paiements directs
s'applique sur le premier pilier
nous nous ne souhaitons même pas que
cette histoire de cofinancement sur le
premier pilier soit une hypothèse de
travail
ce sont aussi nos lignes rockeur et nous
souhaitons créer cette épargne de
précaution précaution comme je disais
tout à l'heure pour les interventions en
cas de crise